After you've hooked the business owner, you're going to send the leads.
You got leads coming in, you hook the business owner, you got to send them a couple leads.
Here's my tip, never send more than five leads, but as soon as they close one, go for the
close.
You send them one lead, they go and run it that night, they close it, go for the close.
Get on a Zoom call, go close it, go for the close.
Now at the same time, do not feel that or think that the business owner has to make
money before you can go for the close because they don't.
And I've got tons and tons of different examples where I have sent two, three leads, the business
owner scheduled one for tomorrow, one for Friday, one for next week, and I just feel
like it's time to go and I've gone and closed the deal tomorrow morning.
They don't even run the leads, much less close the leads.
So don't think that they need to make money at all.
Now if they make money, even better, but if you don't, you don't have to send them leads
until they make money.
You just need to send them leads so they can see the quality and the style and how you
operate and what it's going to be like working with you and make sure it's a great experience.